That product looks organic.
Should I buy it?
Here, here, let me hold it.
Whoa, I'm getting it.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hey, shoppers, this is
D News, and I'm Trace.
When you're at the store how
do you feel about labels like
"cage-free," "organic,"
"not tested on animals,"
"phosphate-free."
Are these claims more likely
to make you buy an item?
And new study in the Journal of
Business Ethics says you will,
especially if it goes
in or on your body.
Researchers from the Concordia
University School of Business
determined when
we touch products
with labels like
"organic," we receive
what's called a positive
contagion effect.
When we come in contact
with or eat something
that has an ethical
feel to it, we
believe those ethical benefits
are transferred into us-- which
I have to say is kind of
weird, but totally true.
They did the research to
find other products that
could be labeled with
ethical branding.
Printer ink, for
example, we don't touch,
so saying biodegradable
won't help its sales.
But moisturizer or paper
towel, we touch a lot,
and every positive touch
reinforces our feelings
of ethical awesomeness.
We explained on D News
a few months back--
organic foods are not more
nutritious than other foods,
though this positive contagion
effect does make us feel better
about eating them.
And "organic" doesn't really
mean what we think it means.
In this country, the US
Department of Agriculture
took over the term
"organic" in 2002.
It is defined as having been
produced using methods which,
quote, "integrate
cultural, biological,
and mechanical practices that
foster cycling of resources,
promote ecological balance,
and conserve biodiversity."
Additionally, things like
synthetic fertilizers, sewage,
or genetic engineering
can't be used.
However, chickens in a
cage-- still organic.
As are cows packed
into a barn eating
genetically modified grain.
The grain isn't organic,
but the cow still is.
Some farmers and activists don't
agree with this definition,
so they've created other
terms, like "pastured," meaning
an animal was literally
raised in a pasture.
The Northeast Organic
Farming Association
created its own "Certified
Naturally Grown" label,
which has similar requirements
to USDA but without control
of the USDA.
Labeling is getting crazy.
As of now, only a small fraction
of the 2.2 million farms
in the United States have been
labeled USDA-certified organic.
The rest can't use
the word "organic"
without paying
fees and navigating
through federal
requirements, lest they
be slapped with a $20,000 fine.
And "organic" isn't the
only label you commonly see
nowadays. "Cage-free"
just means no cages.
That's all it means.
"Free range" means
they're provided an area
to go outside, though that
area can be fenced and covered
and at the far end of a barn.
"Grass-fed" means the
animals are fed mainly grass,
but they can still use
pesticides, hormones,
and antibiotics, and feed
them grain as long as, again,
it's mostly grass.
So knowing all of
this, do you still
feel that positive contagion
effect with organic products?
Are they still ethical?
We'd like to believe so, but
without further research,
we can't really be sure.
What do you think of all
this labeling business?
Do you even care?
Tell us so we know
if we should explore
this more in the comments below,
and subscribe for more D News.
Thanks for watching, everybody.